all right guys I love me those Foreman I
love men on the moon I heard this
documentary was coming out on Netflix I
was really pumped to watch it so I
watched it I didn't plan on doing a
video about it and I really want to talk
about this one so let's talk about it
[Music]
Jim and Andy the great beyond so Jim and
Andy the great beyond is a documentary I
guess Jim Carrey had a camera crew
following him around documenting
everything behind the scenes of the
making of the movie men on the moon for
those of you don't know what man on the
moon is man on the moon is the milos
forman directed biopic about Andy
Kaufman Andy Kaufman was a comedian he
was also ultimately a super troll he was
like an internet troll pre-internet he
was a troll before we knew what a troll
was he's just a guy who likes loggin
with Bebo some saw him as a comic genius
some song as annoying
point is he left his mark Jim Carrey
really wanted to play the role Jim
Carrey played the role and now we see
how Jim Carrey got in through the mind
it hurts stories I'd heard tale back in
the day from the DVD commentary on man
on the moon that Jim Carrey never showed
up for work it was either Andy Kaufman
foreign man who was also latke and Tony
Clifton I love Tony Clifton when this
movie came out man I used to go through
drive-thrus I'd order a bunch of food
that wasn't on the menu go to Taco Bell
I liked pickle on our fries and a
whopper stupid thing is I would eat the
food I actually ordered for real to 98%
I tasted semen in my life and didn't
know but back to the movie you really
did see how manage and carry God and
what makes it great is it's a 20-year
retrospective there are also interviews
with Jim Carrey now talking about his
thought process then what he thinks when
he watches his footage yeah this footage
was never supposed to come out the
studio was like we don't want people
thinking Jim Carrey's an [ __ ] so no
to the release of this footage now
apparently they just don't care or in a
social media world that does have a
market in a place and as sometimes that
meta [ __ ] can really look annoying as
hell like Jared Leto did with the Joker
mailing people Ted rats and condoms and
[ __ ] what it looks like Jim Carrey
did I don't know if he did it on purpose
or accidentally but he created a weird
fantasy pocket he created a bubble where
his fantasy world was just taking hold
and infecting other people I find that
really fascinating at one point in here
it shows Jim Carrey as Andy Kaufman
having a father/son argument with the
guy who plays Andy
means dad in the movie they were arguing
like Andy Kaufman is dead and Andy
Kaufman like Oh like get a job kind of
thing it looks like such a legit
father/son argument and at one point it
looks like Jim Carrey sat down with Andy
Kaufman's daughter and had a
father-daughter conversation whether
their stuff is wild man it really is a
documentary about human connection and
if for nothing else the phenomenon that
if you introduce a life form into an
environment the life form will have to
adapt to its environment but Jim Carrey
a man on the moon created an environment
that just kind of conformed to him like
some sort of gravitational pole maybe
this would have been really annoying to
see you like 20 years ago you're like
dude why is I gotta being a dick behind
sittin cameras are off man just snap out
of it be a human being that's what makes
it really interesting to me seeing Jim
Carrey now talking about how ultimately
everything in your life that happens
touches you and changes you in some way
shape or form you're not the same 20
years later you would have been had you
not had that experience he talks about
how man on the moon has it changed him
it changed his life it touched his life
his life is altered because he took on
that role granted his life is altered
because he took on the grinch I imagine
but this seems to be a really big fork
in the road of Jim Carrey's life my
critique for Jim Carrey I don't know why
I don't know who I am really well Jim
Carrey take it from someone who's made
it and laugh but my critique I would
have is when Jim Carrey is interacting
with Jerry Lawler
on set and cameras aren't rolling he's a
dick to him on set Jim Carrey was being
the Andy Kaufman villain character that
Andy Kaufman and Jerry Lawler used to
tell the entire world but he wasn't
being Andy Kaufman who would have
interacted with Jerry Lawler in a
friendly way if he was actually meta
being Andy Kaufman Andy Kaufman when
cameras were rolling he would play the
role fine then when cameras were off he
and Jerry Lawler would laugh and joke
but instead in this documentary when you
see Jim Carrey and Jerry Lawler
interacting Lawler just looks irritated
I'm sure Jim Carrey knows that I'm sure
he watches this footage like yeah I
should have done the other angle with
that the pretty sure Jerry Lawler never
wants to talk to me again
but as you see in the documentary him
going that direction really does it
creates friction which pulls people
further down into the madness of this
weird construct this fantasy world that
Jim Carrey built on sight I don't know
if I'm telling you to watch and enjoy
insanity play out or watch and enjoy and
interesting behind-the-scenes look of a
movie all I know is I really enjoyed
this I found it really fascinating as a
fan of man on the moon I should review
man on the moon if you're not a big fan
of men on the
if you haven't seen man on the moon if
you don't know much about Andy Kaufman I
imagine you won't get as much out of
this as someone who is a fan of those
things and doesn't know those things but
I still think it is an interesting look
if for nothing else into the eccentric
mind of an actor I watch that after 20
years later talk about his eccentric
mind 20 years ago so check it out it's
on Netflix right now have fun all right
guys so Jim and Andy they're great
beyond have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]